thank you for coming to my talk today
I'll be talking about his stomachs DK it
is a fight on toolkit for analyzing
histopathology data firstly I would like
like to get a sense of my audience so
how many people here do image analysis
of computer vision okay how many people
do machine learning okay how many people
are into biomedical crave okay that's
good so first let's start with telling
about the people behind this work histo
miix TK is being developed as as part of
collaboration between kitware and Emory
University the funding is coming from
Anna night grant from a program of
program that aims to develop information
technology tools for cancer research so
the two faculty members at Emory
University lee cooper and david Cartman
and kid where's the subcontractor on
this grant and these are all the
wonderful wonderful people behind this
work it's not me alone so first I'll
take a moment to tell you about kit
where caper is an open-source scientific
computing company and we have people
with expertise in the domains that you
see here mainly medical image analysis
and computer vision data and analytics
and hype high-performance computing and
visualization we are heavily involved in
developing a lot of open source tool
kits some of the popular ones you
probably might have heard our IDK there
was a talking IDK by Matt a couple days
ago in PI data and there is a slicer
which is a desktop application to view
medical images and analyze them and
cheese see here is the slicer guy get
were so if you have questions you can go
to him and there's VT k which is a very
popular visualization library and see
make which is a cross-platform build
system and there are several other tool
kits which we work on so before I start
with his stomachs DK i would like to
introduce you to histopathology if you
haven't heard of it so what is this the
pathology it is about examining thin
slices of diseased tissue that are fixed
on glass slides you put them under
microscope and look at them at cellular
resolution and you usually apply
chemical stains to them you can think of
them as colored eyes that basically
highlight specific structures in these
images for example nuclei cytoplasm or
other kinds of structures or proteins
that you're interested in right and
histopathology typically look for the
look at the tissue architecture and each
disease has a particular manifestation
of the tissue architecture they look at
the morphology of the cells and nuclei
and extra cellular structures that gives
them information about what's going on
with the disease or whether the diseases
there or not histopathology is stadium
as the gold standard in the diagnosis
staging and prognosis of several
diseases including most types of cancers
so recently there were whole slide
imaging systems developed these
basically scan the entire slide and
produce huge 2d images and so in the
center you see an image basically about
it's at the base resolution it's at 40 x
magnification it's about 50,000 pixels
across the fifty thousand pixels at all
that's about 2.5 billion pixels in
uncompressed format it's about 7.5
gigabytes of data and each of these
images typically contains about a
million nuclei that you want to analyze
right and they're about over ten whole
slide image system vendors right now and
if you look at the PubMed trends there
is an increased interest in whole side
imaging currently and one of the biggest
public data resource for this is the
Cancer Genome Atlas that is spearheaded
by the National Institute of Health this
contains data for 33 different types of
cancers from eleven thousand patients
and it contains data seven different
kinds of data and that's all in all
about 2.5 petabytes of data and there
are lots of studies that are going on
based on this data so a few years ago
before we started on the development of
Islamic ste k these two members that you
see on the right from emory university
develop what is called a cancer digital
slide archive it's basically a viewer to
look at all the whole slide images that
are part of the Cancer Genome Atlas
dataset so they ingested about 30 to 32
thousand whole slide images that come
from about 19,000 patients and 33
different cancer types that is about 15
terabytes of data and the there is link
of each whole slide image to other data
modalities as well so that's a that's a
humongous amount of data and considering
the scale of these images you can
imagine that it takes a lot of time for
histo pathologists to basically go
through the image and arrive at a
diagnosis or a prognosis so obviously
there has been interested in developing
computational techniques to inject some
objectivity into this process so each
disease has a unique manifestation on
the tissue characteristics of these
images they alter the nuclear morphology
in a specific way so what computational
histopathology involves basically
developing image analysis and machine
learning algorithms to basically
quantify these characteristics this
tissue phenomena with some quantitative
features and then there are 2 goals 1
goal is to take these imaging biomarkers
or features extracted from these images
and you correlate them with clinical
survival data or clinical even data to
build survival models to tell how
aggressively aggressive the diseases or
how long the patient will survive and
with that you can build tools decision
support tools to recommend what kind of
treatment the patient should go through
that is one goal and the second goal is
basically to understand tumor biology
itself
you basically correlate this imaging
biomarkers with other genetic variables
to understand the correlations and
hopefully that will one day that will
probably lead us to developing better
cancer drugs so I I've listed out the
key requirements to make all this is
possible first thing is you need a
web-based platform for data management
and also analytics the data sizes are
too high for moving the data around so
you have to bring the analysis to the
data and a second we need there's a need
for an open-source platform as well they
are not many open-source tools in the
pathology domain as compared to
radiology or genomics and we want it
will be open source but also with the
license the permits commercialization
and there's there's a whole lot of data
management needs that come with it and
we need ability to visualize these whole
slide images at different scales to
support the pathologies workflow and we
need ways to do markup on these images
do annotations on these images and we
need a toolkit so the algorithm
community needs a toolkit with
state-of-the-art algorithms to build
upon and they also need a platform to
disseminate their new solutions new
analytic solutions somewhere for wider
use with the community they need and
pathologists also need a platform to
evaluate and pick among all the
state-of-the-art algorithms that are
there and lastly and most importantly we
have to build for the community and
engage them that we will collectively
meet the scientific goals faster so our
solutions are twofold we have one web
application called digital slide archive
it it aims to fulfill the data
management needs of whole slide images
and the other is historic ste k which
aims to fill fulfil the analytics needs
of this data and both these tools are
open source with an Apache two point O
license and both these tools are based
on what is called a go
order on that is under active
development and get where what is gooder
girder is a Python framework it started
as a data management platform but now
it's more than that it is a Python
framework that helps you build web
applications that store manage and
process scientific data that's the way I
would like to put it so it has a restful
access to all the data that is stored
inside and it supports multiple backends
you can have the data on the file system
or Amazon s3 HDFS wherever and then the
search capabilities which can be
improved and you can have users groups
and there is a good or plugin which lets
you do distributed task execution that
is based on salary underneath and
there's a very nice plug in
infrastructure that helps you build
server site analytics applications I
will do a demo of this in a bit and if
you want to get a feel of it you can go
to data or couture com it's a it's based
on girder so you get a feel of it so
i'll start with the Digital side archive
it is basically an extension of girder
these are some screenshots that I put if
the demo doesn't work so let me try so
this is the dashboard of the digital
slide archive it's basically an
extension of girder with a few features
that are specific to histopathology so
there are collections which are
essentially sort of folder folders it's
going to feel like a file explorer to
you so we having we have ingestion
script but that ingests the data from
the Cancer Genome Atlas and and these
are all different cancer types and if I
go into one of the cancer types in a bit
yeah these are all the patients for each
cancer type there are people with the
disease and also people without the
disease so you can do machine learning
on them and yeah it's a bit slow but ok
I have a backup yeah it's supposed to
show thumbnails of those images and if I
go into one of these images
there's an embedded viewer so you can
link custom metadata tags to each of
these images like clinical information
stain type or any other information that
is there right and so there is let me go
the other one so there are different
kinds of acid stores you can have the
data on file system or MongoDB amazon s3
or HDFS you have user and group
management and most importantly there is
all the data is there rest in points to
access the data if there's an extensive
amount of restful access for example I
can download the file upload the file
through last in points okay a little bit
slow yeah so those are all the rest in
points and hopefully my view are loaded
okay it's not loading for anyway so it's
supposed to have an embedded image
viewer so you can zoom through these
images and pan and look at them and let
me go further so coming to his stomachs
DK his stomachs DK is being developed
with the three kinds of communities in
mind the algorithm research community
and the pathologist and cancer
biologists and their two modes of using
historic stick a one is it can be used
as a pure python toolkit for algorithm
development it's it aims to provide
state-of-the-art algorithms for each
component of the data analysis pipeline
so if you're working on one component of
the pipeline you can use algorithms from
historic ste k for the rest and develop
on just that one piece and it can also
be used as a code or plugin for web
based analysis in this mode it provides
a framework to easily expose analysis
modules command line analysis modules on
the web it provides a platform for
researchers to disseminate their
solutions easily for
use with minimal effort on their part
I'll do a demo on that and it provides
also a platform for pathologists and
biologists to look at what analytic
solutions are there from algorithm labs
and pick and choose from them and it has
a back-end engine for distributed task
execution based on salary and and coming
to the first mode of use as a Python
toolkit these are all the algorithms
that we are trying to build into
historic steek a beginning with a be
processing there are already some
functions do color normalization if the
there is non-uniform staining in these
images you can correct for them and
normalize them this color deconvolution
which involves basically you have an
image that we're in multiple streams are
applied and you algorithmically separate
these stains basically if you have
stained that highlights nuclei
understand that highlights cytoplasm and
extra cellular structures you can
separate them and then ran nuclei
detection algorithms on them we already
have some nuclear morphometry and
algorithms there we are working on
selling nuclear classification
algorithms and amino his stomach
immunohistochemistry quantification
which is about staining them with
proteins if you're looking for a certain
proteins that you're interested in and
tissue region classification and lastly
integrative analysis with the genomic
data and we use read the docs for our
documentation that is this is the API
reference that shows a high level view
of the kind of functions that are there
in his stomachs DK and coming to second
mode of use as a girder plugin for web
based analysis this is the dashboard of
web based analysis that's a screencast
screen short just in case the table
doesn't work yeah so so there is a way
to open the image in the link girdle
girdle instance and then there is
analysis maybe I will explain this first
and come back to this
at the core of this is basically I'll be
a very simple framework to expose a
command line analysis modules currently
written in Python or C++ but we can add
other languages as well this framework
exposes any command line analysis
modules on the web there's a protocol
that you need to follow so what the
developers need to do is they create a
folder in their github repository for
each analysis module they write an XML
file which describes the inputs the
types of the inputs the parameters any
default values and outputs of the power
and the output of the algorithm and then
they write a code write the code which
basically ideas to this XML spec so let
me quickly show you on command line how
this works so oops is it big enough
bigger bigger okay
but so in the in his stomach ck itself
there are four analysis modules I will
go into one of them and you have a
folder for each and every analysis
module inside there is an XML file which
describes input parameters and output
and there is a Python file which
actually does the analysis and so this
is how the XML spec looks like this is
based on the slicer execution model this
is what the slicer the desktop
application that i was talking about for
medical imaging uses and we made a way
to expose these modules over the web and
it was very successful with slices there
are hundreds of plugins written by the
community so as you can see there are
like input you can so there's an input
parameter and there are some stain color
parameters and these are the outputs
that this module produces and then there
is this the actual Python code that does
the analysis and what we do what we have
is a Python package called cdk CLI which
does the command line argument parsing
and helps for you let me show you what
the stars if I do dash dash help so you
basically get usage help on how to use
this command line module what it's
basically doing is its parsing the xml
file and generating this for you and it
also has dash dash XML endpoint which
basically throws out the whole XML file
that is what is used to automatically
generate reston point to use that module
over the web so let me go back to my
demo the other thing that you write is
basically a JSON file which lists all
the analysis modules that you want to
expose
yeah okay and then you write the season
file and then you write a simple darker
file you can derive from the historic
steek a stalker image which will install
histo mix TK and all the different
libraries for you and then you install
any requirements of your analysis module
and then you call an entry point that we
provide and let me show you what that
does and the command line again actually
this bigger okay how am i doing in time
so I have a few docker images that were
generated that way and let me run the
historic stick is dr. image if I do dash
dash health so basically generates a
help on how to use the darker image you
can basically run any CLI command line
module inside the docker image and then
there's a dash dash list sí allí
endpoint which basically throws out that
JSON file contents so we there is a
piece of code which basically analyzes
the JSON file and then goes to the
folder which has the analysis module
picks out the XML and then generates the
rest endpoint automatically for you so
and let me go back here and so you
basically build the dockerfile there is
a github hope to automatically build the
docker image and upload it to talk or
hub and there are end points where and I
can simply go and add you can send me an
email saying hey I want to host my
daugher image which contains the
algorithms are left in our lab on your
website and I can simply go to reston
point and add the docker image and it
shows up here and for each docker image
there could be multiple versions and and
then for each for each other major a
bunch of analysis modules that it
exposes and the one you see on the left
is basically the vigil tree to set the
parameters inputs and outputs for the
analysis module and all this is also
automatically generated from that XML
file the developer rights so there's
like very minimal effort on the
developer side to expose that on the web
and yeah so we also have the capability
to render annotations like boxes circles
contours all that kind of stuff
and what this does is it gives a nice
platform that pairs different kinds of
communities so the pathologist's and
biologists have data questions the l
garden researchers get the analytics
needs from that community develop their
algorithms they can use darker they can
use our mechanism to push it to push it
to an image on docker hub and then we
can host it on the website from where
the pathologist and biologists can
access all the analytic solutions
compare between them and choose between
them and lastly uh some of software
process stuff histo mix decays on github
we have documentation on drink the docs
we are working on more documentation
there's a quite a bit there but you are
working on more we haven't made our
official release yet we are waiting
waiting on improving the code coverage a
bit we are about of about sixty percent
code coverage we won't improve it a bit
more we use things to automatically
generate API documentation from the doc
strings inside the functions and there
are some usage examples using Jupiter
notebooks on read the docs and we use
Travis CI for continuous integration and
we use vacant and ansible to ease the
installation process you can go to the
dogs for more details and these are all
the future work that we are planning
will probably make a release sometime
soon and we'll be adding more algorithms
we are looking into ways to speed up
algorithms using scythes on and using
Python wrapped itk for whatever we can
and we are working so in the next year
we'll probably take a big data
processing challenges basically we want
to process the individuals we want to
paralyze the processing of individual
tiles of these whole slate images so
these are basically stored in a
pyramidal fashion and at each level of
the pyramid the image is broken down
into blocks or tiles
right we want to paralyze the processing
of these blocks we are looking at
technologies of how to do this will be
venturing into the ohmic side of things
integrate the into integrative analysis
with genomic and clinical data and a
bunch of other stuff and Couture is
hiding these are all the positions that
are currently up on job store couture
com if you find find one of them
interesting go and apply for them thank
you so thank you we have time for
questions when you ask a question please
take the microphones go to video do you
find difficulty debugging so in the Oval
work floor o Lord O a lot yeah
experiences and suggestions so we had
very minimal exception handling before
we increase that a lot girdle has a way
to log exceptions wherever they occur
should I know there is everything goes
into a log file on the server you can go
and look there so this mix of web
application and scientific development
there like some weird debugging issues
that you face with it so yeah that's
there so we are trying to make it as
easy as possible for the algorithm
dalapathi we want me make it feel like
they're just developing a command line
analysis module they just have to import
a particular python package to command
line argument parsing and it's basically
an executable they can test it on local
files in the command line and as long as
they use the ctk CLI package we will be
able to easily expose it over the web so
yeah we want to make it as easy as
possible for the algorithm developers
they don't have this shouldn't have to
deal with
complexities of exposing their
algorithms or the web and likewise the
pathologist and bio that they don't want
to develop algorithms they just want to
look at different state-of-the-art
solutions that are that are out there
for each analysis component and then
compare them in a black boxes fashion
and then choose among them based on what
works in their data yeah next question
well I I have a question are your
primary users histo pathologist and how
do they feel about their new workflow we
haven't brought this to them yet we
won't do that after our first release so
our collaborators are at Emory
University work very closely with
pathology labs in the university so
they'll be our first users and then we
get a feel of how things are working so
thank you yeah thank you very much if
you are now works so so you can just
zoom through the images and see them
yeah the cause of the live demo thanks